if you having a bad time right now it
cannot last for people talk about money
all the time
rich people talk about things wealthy
people they talk about ideas it's
something waiting for someone to give
you a job three children work he was a
bohemian evangelical Christian and
ordained minister he founded the Bahamas
Faith Ministries International he was a
CEO and chairman of the international
third world leaders Association he's
Myles Munroe and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success rule number
five is my personal favorite I make sure
to stick around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips and as
always as miles of talking if he says
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
change is inevitable change is also the
principle of life that means everything
that is alive will change and even
things that are not alive will change
you know a lady came to me she says I
came to the Bahamas for the last ten
years and I missed four years and I came
here this past month and everything is
different the airport is new she said
what happened to the old airport she
says in other words even the things not
alive are changing the way the river
runs down the mountain is wearing away
the mountain you go back to that
mountain ten years later and the river
is wider change is in creation it's part
of life so here is the question then
ecclesiastical 3 it says to everything
there is a season and to every purpose
under heaven there is a time for it to
everything there's a season how many
things have a season everything this is
one of the best news I ever got in my
life when I understood this I was a
teenager and I changed my life when I
understood that everything is a season
we tell you why if you having a bad time
right now it cannot last
if you cannot find a job right now that
is only a season if your business is
going in the wrong direction it's a
seasonal slide if nobody wants to marry
you that's only a season then I'll come
a season everybody want to marry you
you got choices if you have no money
right now the good news is I am
seasonally broke hey neighbor it's only
for a time that's the good news that's
why we are always reminded never make a
permanent decision in a temporary
problem success is not something you
pursue success has a matter it's a lot
of a show of becoming a person of value
we should not be pursuing money we
should pursue purpose we should pursue
vision for ourselves and for our
countries for our communities we should
be not assuming things we need to pursue
ideas
I always say that there are three types
of people in the world there's poor
people there's rich people and there's
wealthy people poor people talk about
money all the time
rich people talk about things wealthy
people they talk about ideas rich people
poor people and wealthy people plea
differently for example poor people
they pursue money rich doing pursue
things where people pursue ideas and so
the plussing leaders different way of
thinking I hope that the third world
and the young people of our nations will
become ideas people you know ideas
control the world there's more money and
ideas attract money so I think in which
if we could minimize this desire to get
money and elevate the creativity of new
ideas we will find that financial
results will naturally flow to it
Yogi's didn't didn't pursue money even
shoot an idea Steven jobs the way Steven
jobs will been at the Apple Computer and
the iPhone he never went after money he
took of an idea and I think if you think
of all the wealthy people in the world
it was ideas that make them wealthy not
money but sure so I think we are in
construction we reverse it don't pursue
money and then try to get an idea and
get an idea and when you pursue the idea
you become a byproduct as far as wealth
I tells all young people I say to you
right now stop looking for employment
why don't you position yourself
differently and look for deeper to
employers to be employed mean to
somebody else Jenna fitting for your
energy to deploy me to deploy yourself
means that you are using your own energy
to be productive so instead of waiting
for someone to give you a job create
your own work that's why I tell you the
difference between their work and your
job your job is what they trained you to
do your work is what you were born to do
your job is your skill which they can
find you from that in time but your work
is your gift no one to take that from
you your job is where you get
compensation for activity your work is
we get fulfillment because you love it
so much your job you can retire from
your work you can every time for the
work because your work is you so when a
person discovers their work they no
longer need a job but their work makes
them productive so they're young people
in this country who are full of talents
full of gifts and I want to say this to
every problem in life is a business all
businesses are simply someone
solving a problem so the more problems
in our in Kenya the more businesses
available for young people to begin and
this is what I think we're lacking we
are trained to get a job we're not
trained to start a business we are
trained to that other people employers
not trained to deploy ourselves do we
sit down and let change just happen to
us or we just watching change happening
around us or are we aware that change is
happening within us are we going to be
those proactive people who make sure
that we affect what happens to us change
also produces four types of people they
are in the front first of all there are
people who who watch things happen now
let me say something about change this
is important you not all change is
improvement you used to weigh 128
and there are you changed and for some
of you that's not an improvement you
lost your wardrobe you lost your ability
climb of steps fast even lost the
quality of health that you had change
doesn't mean improvement all the time
but the problem is without change there
can be no improvement so you have to
decide what to do a change change will
happen and if you are not careful it
could be destructive so you have to
determine what kind of change do I want
in my life and I want you as a young
person as a mother and a father as a
businessperson to think about your
company even or your family or your
educational pursuit what kind of classes
do you want to take in college this year
what kind of grades do you want what
kind of relationships you want to have
in your life who do you want to drop but
who do you want to pick up in your
relationships what kind of people do you
want to associate with anyone travel
that you've never been what are the
books you need to read you never read
before that the changes come with
choices so what kind of person are you
we shouldn't try to get everything now
in I rented college I spent eight years
in universities I have three bachelor's
degrees a master's degree five Doctorate
degrees bestowed upon me upon by many
different universities and many of my
in the schoolroom in high school they
went straight to jobs I went to college
you know they started making money early
I delayed my money making for five years
and now they make in a year I probably
make it an hour so you know we need to
be more focused on developing ourselves
rather than trying to grab money now
focus on self improvement self expansion
rather than trying to get your pocket to
expand because you the more probable you
make yourself the more value you attract
you not pay for how hard you would you
pay for which you are worth to the
organization that's our and add more
intellectual development you have the
most spiritual develop you you have the
more psychological develop your
emotional stability you become more
vulnerable to the world and let me say
this finally if you become valuable to
the world the world will pay you to be
yourself as well so it's important for
you to become a person of value not to
seek value in things I can tell you for
what I know not what I do and I think
this is what we need to perceive as
being most valuable dealer they actually
call in intellect they call it capital
you know international capitalism is
really a commodity and so
I want to encourage our young people to
focus on on discovering the purpose for
your life why God created you and then
the cellular gives and then refine them
develop them practice them and then even
begin to serve them freely to your
community develop yourself and in a
short time you'll discover that people
will pursue you because when you develop
your fruit and you maximize your fruit
of your gift and the life just like a
tree trees now bring their fruit to you
these are simply manifest them you
attract you are attracted to the tree so
when you develop your gifts and refine
your gifts you don't need to look for
followers they'll find you
that's after or leadership is not about
finding followers it's about followers
being attracted to what you have and
this is true commodity the power for me
to be successful was not in the teachers
it was not in the educational system it
was not in my culture it was not in my
society it was within me and I began to
think God if you are a good god why am i
poor if you are a great God why are
these people better than me if you make
me in your image why are they special
and I'm a monkey and that night no
thunder no lightning no earthquakes
nothing I just heard a voice in my mind
and the voice said I asked you to
believe me and you will be saved not
them and that night I made a commitment
to believe what God said 13 years was
okay I believe that I have the power to
experience far beyond all I can ever ask
think or imagine 13 years old and that's
when my pursuit of God began when was it
that you realize you wanted to become a
preacher you know I didn't want to
become a preacher matter of fact today
is still consider myself a preacher I
think it drove me to have a passion to
help everybody who's been oppressed my
passion is to make sure that no one
it should live under what I experienced
I never desired to be a minister I
desired to help people you should never
judge your success by other people's
accolades you judge your success by
God's instruction to your life and I
well along you are with that instruction
because I found out something in life
the average human being is so mediocre
that their being a genius just do a
little extra your mister people are so
normal to be an expert just go one inch
abnormal and they think you agree so
don't judge your success by the masses
what they think of you judge yourself by
what God told you to do can I put it
another way when experience is your best
teacher then progress is imprisoned
experience could be a curse I've been
taught by my parents years ago that
experience is the best teacher I don't
believe that any more experience could
cause you to stop progressing because
you keep judging your dreams by your
experience or your vision by your
experience and you end up saying I tried
that before
or I never saw anyone do it that way and
you began to use your experience to stop
your progress this is why God always
makes history with young people because
all people got too much experience you
all remember the story with David and
Goliath the problem with Saul who was
the king was he had experience and he
tried to put his experience on David
he told David wear my armor wear my
shield used my sword
David put it on David's that thing is
too heavy and he went out and fought the
Jaya
with something that giant never saw
before a sling how do you fight a rock
with a sword the giant says what is this
thing he's using mr. giant is trained
experienced with a sword so he expected
an experienced swordsman to come and
fight him but here comes a little boy
with equipment he ain't never seen
before we need some people like that in
the 21st century who come with some
faith that they'd never seen at the
office think of some ideas that wreck
the whole system that's why Steven jobs
will always be in history as a great
inventor he keep defying his own
experience I was reading his uh a
document watch a documentary on him the
last two weeks ago and they said that
when the iPhone came out they said to
him that's it you the ultimate this is
it he said no and he came up with his
idea about the iPad and he said the
people in the company said it will never
work why it's it's an abnormal size if
you got a computer or an iPhone put in
your pocket put in your briquette either
this thing in the middle ain't gon work
he says look we gonna make this now the
iPad is the most common machinery people
use in the world sometime you got to
defy your own board to take progress
experience consult your experience but
never let it rule you Shakespeare says
sweet are the uses of adversity I like
that sweet are the uses of adversity he
says you must learn to use adversity for
your benefit one of the wealthiest man
in the United States I just finished
reading his book again is edition new
edition it's called cheetahs never win
he's a multi-billionaire he probably has
products in this room today or in this
building somewhere he is the largest
manufacturer of plastic paper cups and
paper plates Fox in the world the
company is called the Huntsman
Enterprise multi billionaire here's what
he says in this book I just finished
reading
he says if there is a silver lining to
bad times it is this when facing severe
challenges your mind is normally at its
sharpest no wonder why he's a
billionaire when facing challenges he
says your mind kicks in and thinks
beyond the norm
he also says another statement I thought
was interesting he said humans seldom
have created anything of lasting value
unless they were tried or hurting
benefits from crisis this is when you
are supposed to become a greater leader
a better leader because your skills must
be tested I put it another way
Abraham Lincoln was an amazing guy he
became the greatest president in the
midst of trials today I still am
convinced he is the greatest president
of the United States in his
because he used adversity to create a
Federation that lasted 300 years and
still were working but it came out of
the fires of crisis my definition of
leadership is very simple yet
complicated
I believe the leadership is the capacity
to influence others through inspiration
not manipulation and that inspiration
comes from a passion which is motivated
by a sense of vision and a sense of
purpose so leadership is first personal
then its corporate leadership is not
something you pursue is sudden you
discover leaders are born when a human
discovers something more important than
their personal ambition leadership we
don't pass huge leadership discover no
truly did not seek followers leaders
actually are pursuing a passion toward a
purpose that gives them a sense of
destiny for example wonder greatest
leaders of example that I use is Nelson
Mandela one of your great presidents he
never sought followers think about it he
discovered a purpose that was more
important than his private preservation
the private ambition he pursued that
person purpose privately it attracted
people so leaders don't seek followers
followers are attracted to leaders
leaders are more concerned about
discovering a purpose to improve the
life of humanity that's more important
than their personal ambition so they
sacrifice themselves to accomplish
something for the greater good man we
find that very rarely most people recall
leaders are simply professional
manipulators and they actually are more
concerned with their own promotion than
promoting the people as you look back
over your life if there's just one thing
that you could do differently what would
it be hmm that's always that's always a
tough question I get that a question
asks a lot I'm not sure you know because
everything that happened in my life
produced me even the negatives even the
things that I might have failed in the
things I've made mistakes with they work
fantastic classrooms for me and I
believe the best thing in life to do is
not to regret and try to change what
happened but to interpret it properly
maximize it and use it
to serve other people and that's what I
want to do with my past
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because a bell Solomon
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you hear
today that inspired you the most what
was the biggest lesson that you learn
after watching this video I'd love to
hear from you please leave it in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to max young max thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book it
really really really means a lot to me
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
I want to focus on discovering and
releasing how to release your hidden
greatness every human being in this room
and those watching by the internet you
have inside of you I have no doubt about
it
greatness but most people will die
with the greatness on the inside and
this is why we have this conference
because we don't want you to be one of
those persons who die with their
greatness let me say a few comments
about greatness every human desires two
things in life I want you to write them
down two things every human wants six
billion of us and now seven billion
since last May April on this planet want
two things and everything you do is
motivated by these two things one we
want power every young person every old
person wants power we can talk about
what power is and the second thing we
want is greatness we don't talk about
these too much but every human being
wants power and they want greatness this
is why we are motivated to wear certain
clothing we call empower clothing this
is why we try to join a gang because
being in a gang of people gives you
power to threaten other people this is
why you would actually want to steal
money or gain money but money gives you
power to buy things that you want to
make you feel important everything we do
is motivated by these two things power
and greatness now I want to mention
something about power what is power
power I want you to quote it with me out
loud up on the board so you can remember
it when you leave here what is power
read it
power is the ability and the capacity to
control circumstances and in the
environment as power power is what the
ability to control circumstances
and to control your environment that's
what power and everybody wants it the
politician wants it the banker wants it
the parent wants it the young person
wants it everybody wants power to
control circumstances what is greatness
write this down greatness out loud
please is a sense of value importance
and significance that's greatness
greatest when you feel that you are
important to the world you feel great
when you feel that you are valuable to
society
greatness is when you feel that you are
significant to your generation in other
words the desire for all of us to be
great under control our environment is
natural you as a 16 year old your desire
to become the head of the class is a
desire for greatness you as an 18 year
old your desire to go to college and get
a degree so you can get a better job so
you can make more money so you can buy
things you want it's a desire for
control a desire for greatness and this
is why people get in trouble they're
pursuing power and greatness now let me
just repeat again the pursuit of power
one greatness is natural it's a matter
of fact if you don't want to be great
something's wrong with you if you have
no desire to be powerful something's
wrong with you every person here desires
these things I put it this way God is
not against your desire for greatness
he's not against your desire for power
because God created you
to be great contributors who you are but
no one knows it yet
potential that's all you could become
but young becoming yes potential is how
far you can go much other Gandia in
other words potentially it's never what
you've done because once you've done
something it ceases to be your potential
potential therefore hasn't known what
you haven't done yet that you can send
the air to and that's why I am after you
I came up to you because I'm or what
you've done oh boy
the PhD so what if over contract
potential therefore it's not about what
you would change if you haven't achieved
in that you could achieve and this is
why I say this that the any of your
potential write it down is your last
success the greatest enemy of your
attention if your success because when
you become successful at something it
helps you stop this is why I am always
nervous about people
accolades concerning me I don't trust
too many awards you
I have so many degrees to stone the
funding and I hide them away because I
don't even want to see them they may
stop it
nothing is more dangerous
yes
so you possess the potential and is
hidden